it's great to welcome back to the
program dr. Peter Bogosian full-time
faculty member in Portland State
University's philosophy department
author of the best-selling book a manual
for creating atheists he is taking a
pause from his sabbatical to speak with
me today and I'm grateful for that it's
so great to talk to you again you know
we've seen so many conversations new
conversations happening among many of
the newly involved in politics over the
last couple of years about free speech
censorship a free marketplace of ideas
etc and I want to just jump right into
this issue with you are you at all
concerned about some of the resistance
to truly open speech that we're seeing
not just from the usual suspect on the
right but also from some on the left I
would say most on the left yeah that
that is a profound concern to me I think
that with squelch the marketplace of
ideas and so many we've created these
individual bubbles these my subjectivity
matters my offense matters I think we
can't talk about this I think it's a
tremendous problem that prevents people
from sincerely examining ideas difficult
ideas complicated ideas but ideas about
which we must have a conversation well
I've been sort of criticized not not to
put myself at the center of this but
just to have a sort of anecdotal example
I've been criticized pretty heavily by
the left and the right on this issue and
that yeah I I reject the idea that if
everybody disagrees with you you're
doing something right I think that's
sort of fundamentally fallacious right I
could say two plus two is five everybody
would disagree with me doesn't indicate
at all that I'm on to anything but the
point I want to sort of get to is for
example on the issue of terrorism and
it's linked to Islam I've been super
clear that number one it's really
important to know the facts and facts
like for example that in the u.s. yes
most terror is is committed by white men
born in the United States but worldwide
most terror is committed by Muslim men
that's something that
the American conservatives seem to be
angry about because they feel like I'm
ignoring the worldwide reality and some
on the Left get angry about because they
feel like I'm a sort of bolstering
Islamophobia when I'm really just
talking about facts and I've not
effectively found a way to sort of speak
rationally to some of the individuals
who feel that just stating these facts
is in some way misleading are you
experiencing some of the same thing
while there was so much in that that I
have we have to unpack it okay first of
all when people say if you're criticized
for both sides there must be something
there I don't think they're talking
about empirical questions like facts
about the world I know they're talking
about ideas yeah and I don't know
whether or not you may be right I don't
I I don't know it's simply because
everybody criticizes you you know I
could say hey I'm gonna sacrifice a goat
on my car to figure out what the words
mean everybody could criticize me and I
think you're certainly correct just
because you're criticized by everybody
it doesn't really mean anything
certainly people use that as an excuse
to show that they're fair about
something right but I don't think that's
I don't think that does what the people
wanted to do okay next thing the
question about facts the idea that
somebody would be offended by a fact
that's a problem that we need to address
very quickly I'll give you my two second
spiel about why I think that is I think
people have their beliefs are rooted in
their identities and when people think
I'm the sort of person who holds this
belief then it becomes very difficult
for that belief to be revised and then
you need to virtue signal to tell other
people in your community that you are
indeed the sort of you're a good person
you're a decent person no no decent
person would entertain that idea so it
really speaks to that what I consider to
be a very interesting question what
ideas should we entertain and I really
think that one of the most important my
writing partner James Lindsay tweeted
this out and I think it's absolutely
correct
what is the
as we move forward how can we figure out
which voices matter in the conversation
in which do not and figuring that out
that key piece should set the stage for
everything that follows so someone gives
you a fact about Islamic terrorism
someone gives you a fact about white
males committing crimes those are facts
there's no reason to be offended or
indignant at the facts you can be
outraged at the policy implications
based upon those facts anything yeah
absolutely
so the question is how do we have a
conversation with someone about facts
and broadly put I think that the
consequences people are so afraid of the
consequences so to use a previous
example if we're talking about whether
or not we should invade Iraq or
what-have-you or whether or not women
are treated a certain way or people are
so terrified of what that would mean
that they don't want to take an honest
look at what what the facts in question
are and I think that's exacerbated under
the trump administration because in the
Trump administration people are so
terrified of the consequences because it
seemed they seemed to be semi random
they seemed to be like a big grab bag of
anything that that could go wrong has
been going wrong and the consequences as
people don't talk about some issues that
they would ordinarily talk about if
somebody sane and rational and less of
an ignoramus were in the White House is
that could I make that I articulate that
clearly yeah and I think that the the
mention of Trump brings up something
that I think is very much tied into this
which is this concept of overbearing
political correctness and political
correctness is something that during the
campaign Donald Trump blamed for all
sorts of different things and I would
love to get your thoughts on absolutely
precisely when we're talking about
overbearing political correctness let me
give you sort of a tutu path to go down
on this I've been super critical of the
sort of on campus safe space trigger
warning mentality
while at the same time in in a sort of a
pragmatic perspective most of the people
I've spoken to that talk about
overbearing political correctness don't
really have any good examples other than
they feel like when they use certain
slurs they're looked at negatively and
so for me I'm trying to find a sort of
empirical way to assess how big of a
problem this is while on the one hand I
recognize that there are examples from
college campuses that are incredibly
concerning that on a personal level when
I say to people who say overbearing
political correctness is a problem I say
well what is it that you would like to
be saying that you feel like you can't
say anymore more often than not it's
some kind of filler about a group I
could okay so if you're asking the
question what can I personally not say
that I would love to say let me give you
some examples President Trump it still
sounds weird to say that a president has
recently spoken and he's absolutely
correct to do so about the murder rate
in Chicago the murder rate in Chicago is
astronomical what are we gonna do about
the murder rate in Chicago here the fact
the fact is that we have increasing body
counts of young black men who are
killing other young black men now you
can talk about this or not talk about
this but here would be my suggestion for
what I would like to see happen I would
like to see members not me I'm certainly
not qualified to do this but people who
teach police tactics come into a
university and not have a debate but
have a conversation excuse me
have a conversation perhaps with members
of black lives matter about why is it
that the police do that why did the
police say don't get out of the vehicle
why do the police say keep your hands on
the wheel
I'd like to have a conversation about
that so that we could understand and
that's you're gonna Hamas has the idea
that you have conversations of German
philosophers you have conversations to
seek mutual understanding could you
imagine what would happen if I suggested
that conversate
there was no possible way you could have
that conversation violence would almost
definitely ensue
so even beyond political correctness you
have the idea that there are certain
things that we simply can't talk about
and the consequence of not talking about
those things we need to be honest about
and that's more young dead black man
yeah although here's the thing here's
where I want to sort of uh jump in on
that which is what you're saying is
undeniably true however when you look at
the rate of if you are white and the
victim of a crime how likely is it that
the perpetrator was also white the rate
is almost identical to if you are black
and you are the victim of a violent
crime how likely is it that the
perpetrator is black it's very similar
rates so while in the specific area
you're talking about who could possibly
deny what you're saying the broader idea
of the black on black crime epidemic
that part is actually not shown to be
true by the by the data I just mentioned
and I think that the exclusion of that
data is what can sometimes create bias
or an incorrect perception of reality
I'm happy to talk about that data in
fact I just read the chapter for Matt
Thornton book on that he would be a
fantastic guess if you want an expert on
crime and criminal statistics I'm not a
criminal criminologist I have work in
the prison system we have two issues
going on here one we have the actual
empirical issue of crime rates but you
didn't mention in theirs the likelihood
of a black a white man being killed by a
young black man is in fact SMI small but
if you watch Fox Fox News you'd think
that those numbers are radically
disproportionate to what they are right
you have the empirical question and then
you have what I act with the thrust of
my argument is is that we need to have
that conversation we need to have spaces
on universities where we can talk about
that and the response that you gave is a
perfectly reasonable response that's the
sort of that that's the sort of issue
about
which we need to address without
somebody freaking out calling someone a
racist calling somebody a bigot those
sorts of behaviors something in my
throat those sorts of behaviors don't
foster the conversation so we need to we
need to change the mentality around
having discussions like that we've been
speaking with dr. Peter Boghossian
full-time faculty member in Portland
State University's philosophy department
we're going to pause there and pick it
up with him tomorrow and dig more into
the techniques and how we can
effectively have these conversations I'm
of course referring also to critical
thinking and examining our beliefs more
with dr. Peter Boghossian tomorrow we're
continuing our conversation with dr.
Peter Boghossian full-time faculty
member in Portland State University's
philosophy department also author of the
best-selling book a manual for creating
atheists taking a pause from his
sabbatical to talk to us yesterday and
today
so Peter we we left off yesterday
talking about some of the reactions that
take place when we want to talk about in
in your example from yesterday for
example infra black crime in the Chicago
area what what did we not get to in our
conversation yesterday on that issue
well we the my argument was that we need
to have an honest conversation about
that with people who actually understand
the data there are a lot of things going
on there so there if I said to look I'm
gonna actually say to you what do you
think the three elements predictive of
violent crime on I would say oh it's so
my sense would be economic class
education and family situation what do
you mean by family situation in other
words is someone in a situation where
they have absent parents or present
parents I'm impressed
okay it's sex I know that words a very
complication with a couple of sighs word
age
between 16 and 26 and what you said
which no one really wants to talk about
is there an adult male presence in the
home if there's no adult male presence
in the home then that factor along with
the other factors excuse me
greatly increases the likelihood that
someone will be involved in a violent
crime we need to have that conversation
and many people liberals in particular
want to ignore the fact that having an
adult male in the home it is a criminal
genic factor conservatives on the other
hand excuse me conservatives on the
other hand want to deny that there are
structural barriers and structural
inequalities that contribute to those
variables I want to say something else
it's interesting that if we criticize
the right in today's climate we're all
of a sudden some kind of a leftist if we
criticize stuff I try to I try to
disperse my criticism dispense my
criticisms equally it's hard though
because I mean academia and more of this
stuff about political correctness comes
at me from the left so I'm seeing this
an animal personal level but so back to
the issue of crime and crime rates we
should be able to have that discussion
dispassionately at the very least we
should be able to listen to people who
are experts in the subject during and I
am NOT an expert in the subject area we
should be able to listen to people have
those conversations and then use that to
inform our public policies but those
conversations are not happening on
college campuses again I would invite
any of your listeners to go to their
chair people to go to the department
chairs and say hey let's bring in the
police tactics people in the black lives
matter to have a conversation you see
what would happen if you tried to have
that conversation when we talk about in
order to have those conversations I mean
I'd love to hear from you and this sort
of relates to what you've written in
your book a manual for creating atheists
what would you say are I don't know
maybe to get us into this this direction
some of the most effective and least
effective
waise strategies specific strategies for
having these conversations in other
words in your experience what works in
getting people to critically examine
their beliefs in a way that does not
ignore empirical realities and what is
less effective
that's a great question my app atheist
also deals with that it guides people
through exactly those sorts of
conversations look just think when you
you go to I was at the car dealership
yesterday my friend Adam reads from the
herd mentality podcasts famously a road
nobody wants to buy a car from someone
who screams at them so people change
their beliefs from a point of view of
safety if somebody's a jerk I was
sitting at the dealership yesterday
while my car was there and someone said
Oh sir you you look thirsty no I didn't
look I don't know someone looks thirsty
any handed me a bottle of water somebody
else came to start so we can pull that
from the literature that the Christians
have called relationship advantage Eliza
basically you just want to listen
you won't understand there's something
called Rappaport's rules that Dan
Dennett writes about you want to first
really know what you want to build a
rapport and really know and really
understand what it is that someone is
talking about often somebody is not
talking about the things that you think
they're talking about for example when
someone raises their hand in class it's
not because they necessarily want to
know the answer to the question maybe
they want someone else to know how smart
they are maybe they're trying to impress
themselves for to a woman or a girl or a
boy or what-have-you sitting next to
them maybe they they who knows why they
raise their hand and why they ask
questions human beings are complicated
so you really have to listen to try to
understand what it is that somebody is
saying the the most important thing is I
think you have to be willing to revise
your beliefs because it could be the
case that you're harboring under a
falsity of reality bringing it back to
the earlier conversation that's why I
didn't say a debate between the people
who engage in police tactics and black
lives matter I said a conversation
because a debate you hunker down to win
debates are almost never good ideas well
along those lines
Peter I mean a con I'm curious what you
think a question I've been sort of
trying to end
to interject into conversations that
that at least start to become debates is
what kind of evidence would cause you to
change your mind because sometimes the
the I get the impression that there is
no such evidence and I start to question
whether you can even really have a
worthwhile conversation with someone who
says there's no evidence that I could
even imagine that would cause me to
change my mind is that a waste of time
to talk to someone who can seed that
that's awesome that's the de feasibility
test that's the one of the most if not
the most important things you can have
in your your tool set your bag of tools
what evidence could I provide you with
hypothetical or otherwise I'm not saying
I can provide you with this evidence but
what can I provide you with now they can
say something absurd like the famous
example the bones of Christ you present
me with the bones of Christ and then I
won't believe Jesus is divine they could
say there is no evidence now if they say
to you well there is just simply no
evidence that would cause me to change
my mind then you can say that's great
then don't say you formulate your place
in the basis of evidence because if you
formulate your beliefs on the basis of
evidence that must mean that by
definition that means that there must be
some piece of evidence that could come
in that would cause you to change your
mind so then you turn the conversation
to okay so you don't form your beliefs
on the basis of evidence thank you very
much for being honest what do you form
your beliefs from the base up do you
Disick because they make you feel good
because you want to be a member of a
community and alleged to hold these
beliefs but yes the de feasibility test
is incredibly useful it is your sense
that you can still have productive
conversation with someone who says there
is no evidence that could change my mind
I mean it seems to me that on so many at
least speaking about political issues
when it comes to for example if a
Republican says I want to reduce the
number of abortions and you say well
here's evidence that if you give access
to birth control and and sex education
fewer people get pregnant
and since pregnancy is one of the key
causes of abortion it reduces the number
of abortions they say nope know that I'm
just I'm against birth control and I'm
against sex education
well what would cause you to be in favor
of the
I've already shown you that it that
reduces abortion they say nothing where
do you go from there okay so uh quick
little snippet to your technique you
don't use the word I because then you
make it personal so you just made it
personal so and then you use the word
you probably a bad idea too because then
that right because you don't want to
make this a kind of a personal things
yeah well what do you think would cause
somebody independent looking at in other
words you switch it from them so you
some somebody who's objective or
somebody who has no dog in the fight
what do you think would would cause that
rational person to change their mind
well if they say I'm against birth
control everybody should be against
birth control you say well why do you
why why why is that a problem and they
could say to you something like well
it's in the problem because you know
Jesus said in Matthew I have known you
before you were born and we have this
directive okay so then you would ask you
would ask them without asking them
specifically that to pro hierarchically
prioritize those values so for example
is it what do you think is the graver
problem that we have more abortions or
that people use birth control
christopher hitchens when he was devil's
advocate for mother Teresa hinted at
that and he's written about that
extensively you can read about that so
basically you're asking people to do
their own moral triaging just through
asking questions but because someone
fails the de feasibility test that
doesn't mean you should give up hoping
them I've given up I've never given up
hope on anybody I've spoken to I've
spoken to I can't even tell you how many
thousands of people and sometimes years
later people will come and say hey I had
that conversation and you know it got
the wheels trained fact I was just
talking before this - Anthony Magna
Bosco and excuse me people come up to
him and say hey you know I had this coat
you really made me think about this etc
so somebody who fails to diffuse ability
test maybe that creates a little wedge
or a little opening in their beliefs in
the way they view reality
but it's really don't give up on anyone
I mean we know for a fact people change
their beliefs about things all the time
a lot of this material and and
strategies and thinking are in dr. peter
berg oceans book a manual for creating
atheist which i've read and can
recommend to you peter so great to talk
to you thanks for taking a brief pause
from your sabbatical to do the interview
thanks i appreciate that very much and I
love you Sean I love the work you do and
I appreciate it you're a voice that we
need very much right now thank you